hi everybody I'm Edie Platt I work here
at MIT at the Center for civic media and
earlier this year I read an article
about a guy who appeared to be drunk all
the time
but the weird thing was he didn't
actually drink so doctors kind of looked
at him tried to figure it out it turned
out he had a colony of yeast living in
his stomach fermenting his food into
alcohol so that was really interesting
but that's not the most interesting
thing I learned this year I like to make
things so I decided I should make
something with yeast you can make bread
you can make alcohol
I decided make bread that's how I roll
yeah thank you bread is really old it's
been around at least as long as ancient
Egypt the tomb of Ramses the third has
bread-making depicted and the oldest
type of bread is sourdough which has in
addition to the yeast lactic acid
bacteria is the same stuff in yogurt so
it's a symbiotic colony and if you mix
those two together so here just a cup of
flour and a half cup of water will
culture a group of lactic acid bacteria
and yeast that will continue living and
surviving as long as you feed it so when
you mix it together this is what you
actually get you just get some goo so
what do you do with the goo if you want
to make bread well you just leave it out
so that's pretty easy actually and after
you leave it out for a while if you
leave it at the right temperature it'll
start to activate the microbes well it's
you know some of us know here in
Massachusetts it doesn't always get up
to 70 degrees you know all times of the
year so some people leave their starters
by a heater or something like that I
naturally saw an engineering problem and
realized that aquarium Supply stores
have lots of things for promoting
conditions for life and I bought an a
aquarium heater to build a bath to keep
this at the perfect temperature so after
about 24 hours what you get
is you start to get some bubbles that's
gas being released from all these
microbes in the flower and what you do
is you have to keep feeding it so what
you want to do is empty almost all of it
out just keep a little and then add
another cup of flour 1/2 cup of water
stir it up and now that it's getting
active you wait only say 12 hours and
after about 12 hours it'll it'll rise
the the gas will start to get trapped
and it'll expand so you keep doing that
in in cycles of 12 hours and eventually
it'll double in 12 hours and then you
know it's ready to make bread so you get
your ingredients you need gluten and and
carbohydrates so you know you can't buy
that at the store unless you're a
scientist
so I went to market basket and got flour
which has all of these you mix that with
some water salt and sugar it's amazing
how little you need to make bread you
just mix it all together into a dough
ball like this and again you just sit it
out you know maybe throw a wet towel
over it to keep it from getting dry and
after about eight hours say you know
after you're sleeping or going to work
you take off the towel and it's like
magic it you get it doubles in size I
still haven't gotten used to this yet
and this is the best part this is my
favorite part you then get to pretend
it's something you don't like
like the patriarchy or a sports team you
don't like and you punch it down and
there's there's a full-length version of
this on my Twitter that I couldn't put
in the Excel or the PowerPoint and then
you need it and needing it is really
neat on a microscopic level I learned
what's actually happening happening is
there's the glutens and they're sticking
to each other and forming these long
long chains that make it springy and
elastic and help the bread be soft so
after that you throw it in a pan and it
looks like it's but ready to bake but
not quite you have to let it rise again
so you form it put it in the pan and if
you let it rise for a couple hours and
then you bake it for about thirty
minutes and you get bread
and it's actually really simple it takes
a while but it doesn't take a lot of
work and there's one more step that's
really important when you're making
bread which is of course you have to cut
it up and share it with your friends and
enjoy the bread so that's really the
most important thing that I learned or
the most interesting thing I learned
this year was how to make bread and I'd
like to in this spirit encourage you to
share the things that you make with your
friends